hey what's up guys my name's samuel
leeds and welcome to this week's q and a
sunday i've been investing in property
now for 12 years
and i'm gonna be answering your property
investment questions
right here right now on this video
please do me a massive favor though
and smash the like button also i want to
answer more and more questions so if
you're watching this right now
please comment your questions below
right now in property i really believe
that the reason that people aren't where
they want to be in property
is simply because they have they're
stuck and they if they just had someone
answering their questions you would make
a massive massive difference
so i'm here i've been investing now for
in property for 12 years
i've got quite a big property portfolio
i've had things go good i've had things
go bad
so comment your questions below right
now and i'll answer your questions on
the next q a
sunday if you're not subscribed please
also subscribe
turn the notification bell on imagine if
i was answering your question
you didn't even know i was answering it
because you weren't subscribed and you
didn't have the notification bell turned
on that would be disastrous so do that
right now
and let's see what we've got from last
week so ollie rose says hi
samuel i'm currently 18 and working a
part-time job was wondering what
different places you recommend
i ask for work experience to build up my
property
knowledge great question ollie and
respect for being on the channel so
if you're looking to do work experience
i mean the first thing i want to say is
you're on the
i like the way you're thinking because
most people think in terms of trading
their time for money so most people are
thinking you know i just want to get
paid robert kiyosaki says the rich
people don't work for money
and i think working for free to gain
knowledge
is a very smart thing to do so firstly
you're on the right tracks
in terms of how to get somewhere for
work experience i wouldn't necessarily
go and approach large companies like
estate agents and say hey
can i work for you for free i'd be more
inclined to go to a property networking
event or go on the facebook groups
and find people individuals that are
investing
maybe they haven't got a big company or
lots of staff find individuals
and say hey listen i've got a bit of
time on my hands can i come and be your
right arm and be your assistant
for a few months i think you're going to
learn a lot more because you're going to
be talking direct to the developer
direct to the investor
and i think that rather than you know
licking stamps
and posting letters you're actually
going to be out on the road that's what
i would do so
and maybe not just work for one when i
started out and i was 17
i was renting out people's rooms for
free so i was just like
lots of different investors so it wasn't
like i
were getting work experience it wasn't
official it was kind of off the record
so just find people that are in the
business find people that are doing okay
and volunteer your time for free hope
that helps good job
and good luck sam hawkins hope you're
well sam he says hi samuel we're
negotiating a lease option agreement as
i understand
anything that is negotiated has to be
put in a heads of terms
my question is when and where would you
get this done
and would the heads of terms template
have to be written up by
a solicitor thanks again so sam
no the heads of terms would not have to
be written by a solicitor
heads of terms can be written by
yourself the heads of terms is very
simply the agreement that you send to
the solicitor
and then the solicitor turns it in to an
actual legally binding
contract the heads of terms can be used
as a bit of a pre-contract
usually when a vendor is selling their
house and they sign the heads of terms
in their mind they've signed it so it's
it's like contractual but
in actual fact is not legally binding
until the solicitors are then turned
into an actual legally binding contract
but now you can write it up yourself and
you can do it just literally
on word document in 20 minutes and that
can be your memorandum of understanding
your heads of terms hope that helps
thank you for the question
what else do we have um nathalie naylor
really appreciate the info samuel is
rent to rent
a non-passive strategy would you
recommend a management company to turn
it passive
is rent to rent only possible in a city
you live in nearby
so you can do tenant viewings etc um
so nathalie what i would probably say to
you rent to rent
generally speaking is not something
that's going to give you
passive income now it's going to give
you recurring income
so you can quit your job and you can get
a couple rental rents and it's going to
give you a recurring income
and for sure i mean you can make
anything passive you can make deals
sourcing
passive by recruiting staff to run the
business for you
but rent to rent is a business and it's
got some massive pros to it because
you're going to be able to get recurring
income
you're going to be able to get pretty
good income low entry doesn't cost a lot
to get started
um but i wouldn't get into passive
income like sometimes people advertise a
passive income
um property they're like hey you can buy
this rent to rent deal off me
uh you know pay me three grand and it's
currently generating a grand a month
it's not it's it's like buying a
business you're gonna have to work the
business so um
can you make your passive income yes but
if you're just getting started i
wouldn't i would i would
if you want passive income make money
off of rent to rent
use that money to put into a pot to
invest
in property yourself um that would be my
advice
generally speaking and that's me being a
little bit of a pessimist
um and i am an advocate for rent to rent
i am an advocate for deal sourcing i am
an advocate for active income
as long as you're making money over here
active income and then you're investing
money over here passive income so if
you're doing that you're going to get
wealthy if you're doing
active active passive active active
passive
that that's how people get wealthy
that's what i do and that's what most
successful business property
entrepreneurs do hope that helps but
there guys if you enjoyed the video
please do me a massive favor
smash the like button i'd really
appreciate that and don't forget as well
if one question leads to another
question
comment your questions below i'll be
answering more next week
all right mattio 24 russia says
great advice as always i have a question
i don't have enough money to put a
deposit down on a house
and i find it hard to raise finance
would you advise me to save up
wait and use my own money or try
something else thanks
thanks so much matio so listen um if you
haven't got that much money
you say you're struggling to raise
finance what are you trying to raise
finance for the number one scale is to
get
good deals if you get good at finding
deals usually the money will start to
then come
so you say you're struggling to raise
finance i'd love
if i picked up the phone right now
matthew i'd love to do this if i knew
your number i'd just pick up the phone
right now if i picked up the phone right
now and called you up and said
i got 50 grand you know what's the plan
i have a feeling that you probably
wouldn't be able to say it to me awesome
samuel you've got 50 grand
here's my opportunity here's my deal i
got it lined up and you you probably
won't be able to pitch me
you probably couldn't close me so number
one you've got to get to close
number two you've got to have an
opportunity right you've got to have
actual deals
uh but next if you if you if you're
wondering about what to do with a little
money down
there's loads of strategies with a
little money wouldn't you advise me
save up and wait no i wouldn't advise
you wait i'd advise you save up i'm a
both man
okay rather than saying should you save
up and wait before you get started say
no
save upon weight and get money but then
at the same time
you should be out there learning other
strategies with low money down you
should be out there learning how to
close you should be out there getting
opportunities lined up
so deal packaging rent to rent raising
finance to put into your own brr deals
alongside saving up your own money i i
think you just got gotta be more
um everything just go for it i wish i
knew your number i'd pick up the phone
right now
okay next josh josh ayers
hello there samuel just wanted to say a
big thank you for everything you've
taught me so far my property career
you're so welcome i've just turned 20
however but my first property at the age
of 19. respect
that's that's a massive achievement i
plan to expect my property
i plan to expand my property portfolio
as much as i can throughout my 20s
a couple questions when it comes to
purchasing my next house do you think
it's better to get a fixed rate mortgage
or a variable mortgage at this time
that's his first question but there's
more he's being greedy for a q a sunday
greedy greedy on a q a sunday good for
you i like that
um fixed rate mortgage or variable fixed
rate
interest rates right now are as low as
they've been in hundreds of years
it was 1600s when they're as low as they
are right now
so are they gonna get any lower i doubt
it are they going to go up in time
probably are they going to go sky high
real soon i don't think so i'd be fixing
my interest rates for as long as i
possibly could
not doing variable why'd you variable
when you can fix them you can fix
interest rates for years
is it a mortgage is there mortgage
advisor the best option when it comes to
finding the best mortgage deal from the
bank or do you find
try and find the best loan yourself
don't try and find the best loan
yourself
always use a broker because a a an
independent mortgage broker has access
to all of the lenders all of the banks
so i would ask a broker to find you a
mortgage
uh rather than looking yourself
definitely don't walk into your bank
people always say to me i can't get a
mortgage i'm like
who've you spoke to i spoke to santender
bank i'm like well that's stupid
don't go and speak to santander bank
you've got to because they might they
might say no
but there's hundreds of lenders you want
to speak to a broker
that can assess you and can find the
right lender for you not only is it
quicker
not only more like to be accepted but
you're also going to get the best rate
alright last question from this dude
says do you think it's better to buy a
house
whilst there's no stamp duty or shall i
wait for the crash that will come after
march 2021 thanks again appreciate it
listen i wouldn't buy a house just to
save stamp duty
i don't think that's smart it's like
letting the tail wag the dog you don't
you don't worry about saving stamps you
worry about making money
don't try and save money try and make
money they say look after the pounds
and sorry look after the pennies the
pounds will look after them themselves
i disagree with that statement i think
look after the the pen is too close so
you keep watching pennies
and you lose the million you know you
keep i'm going to try and save stamp
jewelry i'm going to buy a house really
quick
during the manufactured mini boom right
now we're in a manufactured mini boom
because of what's going on with with
furlough we've stamped with stamp duty
holiday
with um bounce back loans and i
predicted this would happen you go back
you watch my prediction video
from a few months ago before any of this
stuff happened i said
what's going to happen is boris
johnson's going to make a manufactured
um he's going to try and make the
economy better
and then what happened suddenly it's a
case of like oh you know half price off
your food and stamped you holiday
trying to boost the economy i predicted
that would happen
um so it's for you to be a rushing idiot
to be like i'm going to rush because i
want to get
get the most of the half-price food no i
want to make the most of the stamps you
hold it no
just buy what makes sense for you at the
right time also should you wait for the
the crash that will come after march
2021
i don't know i don't know how you can be
so specific geez man even the experts
like
should i wait for the crash that will
come after march 21
all right um i do think there's going to
be a crash i do think there's gonna be a
dip
i think there's gonna there's a
manufactured boom right now then there's
gonna be a dip but then what's gonna
happen down the line there'll be a boom
again
property prices go like this up down up
down up now look down that's what
happens
you need to buy for cash flow you don't
wait till the perfect time
you don't know oh should i buy now
should i wait oh wait a bit oh actually
i'm not sure
then you'll be dead so you just got to
buy
at a time whereby you're getting cash
flow cash flow is kicking cash is not
king
even warren buffett says cash is trash
cash flow is king capital appreciation
doesn't pay the bills you can't predict
it for sure anyway so
buy when you find the right deal forget
the standard holiday
forget the potential crash buy when you
find the right deal that's giving you
cash flow that's giving you a positive
roi that'll be my advice hope that helps
if you're enjoying the video smash the
like button sophia
mick sophie nick i'm buying my first
home and i want to rent one room out
i'm aware i can get 7 500 pound attack a
year tax-free but if i rent two rooms
that what happens then
which steps would i need to take or can
my first time be a hmo or a buy to that
so yes if you buy a house and you rent
out one of the rooms to a lodger
you do get i think it's called bedroom
tax relief where seven and a half
thousand pounds is tax free
that's amazing so you rent out a room
you get seven and a half thousand pounds
profit and you pay zero tax i think what
you're asking is what was if you then
wrote another room now you can't do that
it's seven and a half thousand pounds in
total that's my understanding if i if
if it's not then that's going to be
groundbreaking but i'm pretty sure that
it is
seven and a half thousand pound in total
um can you can your first
home be at hmo um yeah potentially you
could rent it out by the room you can
definitely buy a house and then rent out
a room
to a lodger 100 first time round but
listen i'm not a tax advisor i'm not a
mortgage advisor go get professional
advice on that
go kick some ass good luck all right
rochelle says can you do a lease option
agreement and then mortgage afterwards
on the same house yes you can
there are complications around that
because lenders won't like lending you
money on a property when you've
previously had an interest in that house
the way around it
is to buy it cash slash borrow money and
get a bridging finance
loan on it buy it then do a little
refurb because you've done it on a lease
option agreement chances are it will
need a bit
it will have a bit of wear and tear
anyway then refinance it back up to its
true value
and then pull the money out lease option
combined with brr
the alternative to that if you don't
want to do that
is when you you've got a lease option
agreement between you and the seller
when you go to buy the house buy set up
a new company and buy it through the
company
and then that way and this doesn't
always work but it's worked
just speak to speak to a solicitor but
what you can do is buy it
through the company not you so then the
lender is going to be like okay
samuel leads the company is buying this
purple rain limited whatever not samuel
leeds
so the mortgage ability is not such an
issue but of course you own the company
and you're going to buy it for a company
anywhere for tax reasons
um but it can vary from lender to lender
but i know that that is a strategy
around it that
many people have used hope that helps
okay we're just gonna do a
couple more questions what we got what
we got what we got adam perry
sammy on 17 i'm looking to start deal
sourcing business in the next year or
two and i'm finding it difficult to
practice on finding the roi value of the
property is this possible without
calling up the agent and going to view
the property
yeah you can work out the return on
investment without viewing the property
but it's just going to be a very
estimated return on investment because
you don't know things like
you why would you not want to view the
house why would you not want to call it
the agents
and why would you want to bother working
out the roi without even phoning the
agent
geez you could spend four hours doing
due diligence on a house
doing spreadsheets then you call the
agent up in the edge you go oh that sold
yesterday sorry
like just get out there view the
properties you when you view the
properties what happens is
you think i didn't realize this needs
more work than i thought actually the
rentability could be worse than i
thought because it's opposite of really
noisy sharp and
and suddenly things start happening so
you can work out an estimate roi
but i wouldn't even bother if it looks
like it's good go view the house if the
house sucks doesn't matter
see it as an appointment with an estate
agent not the viewing of a house
and don't be afraid to pick up the phone
like crazy you know
the person that books the most viewings
is the person that makes the most money
and the person that puts the most office
forward is the person that gets the most
houses you just got to be super super
active
don't be set on spreadsheets working at
roi on houses that you've never even
viewed in my opinion
maria twenty thousand pound savings
unemployed with the intention to focus
on property investing is there a way to
do a brr
to begin with or are rent to rents the
only way in this case
you've got 20 000 pounds that's 20 000
pounds more than a lot of people are
rent to rent the only strategy no
brr for sure it depends on what your
goals are
you want to get quick cash flow coming
in you might want to do rent to rent
because brl is going to be much more
about wealth building than it is about
quick cash flow
depends on what you want but the world
is your oyster all right last question
last question hope it's a good one
rochelle metta he says hey samuel i'm
going to university next year and i was
thinking about buying a four bed flat
when i go when i go for about 250 000
pounds
that way i can charge my other three
roommates
rent and use it to pay off the mortgage
do you think this is a good idea or
should i wait
and invest in a normal house i wouldn't
invest in a normal house i would do very
similar to what you're thinking about
i wouldn't do anything normal i wouldn't
have a normal job i wouldn't rent a
normal house
i wouldn't um do the normal the normal
thing which is what worked 40 years
for 40 hours a week to retire on 40 of
what you couldn't afford to live on in
the first place i wouldn't do that
that's normal
buying a house living in it and then
renting the rooms out
financially is genius probably wouldn't
go for a flat i'd probably go for a
house
um where you can do the same sort of
thing in buy low rent high
but it's a great great strategy hey i
hope you enjoyed this video
thank you so much for watching smash the
like button if you liked the video if
you hated the video
then you can smash the dislike button
but i hope you liked it drop your
questions in below i'm going to be
answering more questions next week
and don't forget to subscribe turn the
notification bell on and i'll see you
next time